corona und wie das jetzt alles ganz neu
angegangen werden soll und zwar
generalstabsmäßig er ist die neue
speerspitze im kampf gegen korona genau
das ist nämlich carsten bräuer als
kommandeur des kommandos terry
territoriale aufgaben hat er unter
anderem die bundeswehr einsätze
koordiniert im rahmen der krone
amtshilfe und auch die aufräumarbeiten
nach der flutkatastrophe jetzt ernannte
ihn bei kanzler olaf scholz zum chef des
corona krisenstabs ja aber was ist das
für ein mensch hat der ehemalige
brigadekommandeur der
panzergrenadiere das zeug disziplin und
ordnung in das chaos zu bringen wir
fragen die experten dafür aus war marie
agnes strack zimmermann die
verteidigungspolitikerin der
fdp-general breuer persönlich
erzählen sie uns was ist er für ein
mensch
also es wird mit sicherheit die
möglichkeit geben dass sie ihn auch
kennenlernen
general pro jahr fällt dadurch auf dass
er eben wichtige entscheidungen schnell
trifft das ja persönlich ein unglaublich
netter mensch ist und was mich
fasziniert dass selbst im größten krisen
er eine unheimliche ruhe ausstrahlt und
ich hatte ihn kennengelernt vor
anderthalb jahren er ist ja in berlin in
der julius-leber-kaserne und organisiert
das thema corona also die hilfe der
landkreise der städte und das hat er
bisher fabelhaft gemacht und ich freue
mich sehr das habe ich auch direkt zum
ausdruck gegeben dass er diese aufgabe
übernimmt frau zimmermann ist es schon
eine weile her im februar haben sie den
massiven und monatelangen einsatz der
bundeswehr im rahmen der korona
amtshilfe noch kritisch gesehen wir
können da einmal ein zitat von ihnen ein
blenden sie haben gesagt die bundeswehr
kann zwischendurch helfen aber sie ist
nicht das thw genau hier sehen wir das
zitat nochmal ja in diesen stunden läuft
die operation kleeblatt wo die luftwaffe
eben corona patienten verlegen und auch
erste amtshilfe sind beantragt jetzt
steht ein general an der spitze der
pandemie bekämpfung kann es die
bundeswehr dann eben doch besser als das
thw nein also ich hatte das seinerzeit
gesagt und es ist nach wie vor meine
meinung dass sie die bundeswehr nicht
lücken füllen kann die in den städten
und gemeinden bestehen wenn die
bundeswehr hat bis zu ich will keine
falsche zahl nahm 20.000 soldaten
soldaten waren im einsatz im letzten
jahr zum beispiel über ostern um in
altenheimen zu testen um die
gesundheitsämter in den städten und
landkreisen zu entlasten das war gut
gemeint aber die primäre aufgabe der
bundeswehr ist natürlich die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung und sie dürfen nicht
vergessen dass die männer und frauen auf
einsätze weltweit vorbereitet werden und
wenn sie eben in den gesundheitszentren
sind dann kann das nicht stattfinden wir
haben heute eine situation dahingehend
dass es um die organisation geht und
zwar um die logistik nämlich den
impfstoff überall hin zu bringen
präsent zu sein und das ist ja noch mal
eine andere nummer und da ist die
bundeswehr natürlich in logistik im
sanitätsbereich unschlagbar gut aber es
kann immer nur eine zusammenarbeit mit
den zivilen dienstleistern geben ist
übrigens auch ein hinweis darauf dass
wir auf dauer das auch verstetigen
müssen dass die cd dienstleister die für
die sorge die sorge dafür tragen müssen
dass den zivilisten vor ort ist gut geht
dass die zusammenarbeit mit der
bundeswehr aber general breuer um darauf
zurückzukommen ist der richtige mann
weil das hat er ja die letzten
anderthalb jahre gemacht es bleibt aber
auftrag der bundesrepublik sich so zu
organisieren dass in zukunft geben die
bürgerinnen bürger geschützt werden und
das jetzt general breuer vorübergehend
eingesetzt wird wir haben das ja auch in
anderen ländern gesehen ist das sehr gut
geklappt hat begrüße ich ausdrücklich ja
beispielsweise in italien da das sehr
gut geklappt auch vom militär
organisiert aber sie sagen sie begrüßen
den general das vorübergehend zu machen
wir wollen mal hören war es olaf scholz
gestern im großen bild interview hier
dazu gesagt hat wie er den general sieht
ich habe mich sehr
gefreut dass der general mehr zugesagt
hat für diese schwierige aufgabe der
viel erfahrung in deutschland genau
solchen krisen und ist ein sehr
erfahrener mann der auch mit vielen
anderen gut zusammenarbeiten kann worauf
es hier ankommt
frau strack zimmermann
das werden sie unterstützen sie haben es
vorhin auch schon gesagt dass andere das
olaf scholz in diesem interview gesagt
hat und da würde uns auch noch ihre
meinung interessieren ist er hat sich
also erstmals offen hierbei bild für
eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ausgesprochen hat gesagt darüber soll im
bundestag abgestimmt werden die
abgeordneten sollten frei ohne
fraktionszwang nach ihrem gewissen
entscheiden halten sie das für richtig
dass es nun doch eine allgemeine
impfpflicht geben soll gegen die ja vor
allem die fdp also ihre partei sich
immer widersetzt hatte also gegen eine
impfpflicht haben sich alle wieder
selbst sind das können sie schauen dass
wir jetzt sparen die kanzlerin alle
vehement dass ausgeschlossen haben und
ich begrüße dass der zukünftige
justizminister der fdp kollege marco
buschmann in den vorschlag gemacht hat
und der kanzler der zukünftiges
aufgegriffen hat es handelt sich hier um
eine gewissensentscheidung und dass wir
in der kommenden woche im bundestag
darüber debattieren und jeder nach
seinem gewissen entscheiden muss und
darf und es keinen fraktionszwang gibt
gibt es kommt eine impfpflicht oder
nicht finde das sehr gut und sehr
wichtig war dass jeder für sich
letztlich entscheiden muss ich glaube
angesichts der instanzen die fragen mich
auch persönlich und das ist für liberale
nie ganz einfach zu beantworten ich
persönlich rein persönlich kann mir eine
impfpflicht vorstellen denn zur
liberalität und zur freiheit des
menschen gehört auch verantwortung zu
übernehmen verantwortung zu übernehmen
für sich selbst aber eben auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen für eine
gesellschaft und angesichts dieser
unglaublichen instanzen die wir ja vor
einem jahr nicht hatten erinnere mich
auch an schalten mit ihnen wo wir von
instanzen von 50 bis 100 sprachen das
kommt einem jahr heute geradezu niedlich
vor dass man eben auch darüber
diskutieren muss wir diskutieren in der
fraktion darüber wie sie es gehört und
jeder kann dann für sich entscheiden was
er für richtig oder nicht richtig
erachtet ich finde dass großartig und in
einer demokratie auch sehr würdig aber
habe ich sie richtig verstanden die
sitzung im bundestag und auch die
abstimmung wird dann bereits die nächste
woche stattfinden ja wir haben ja
nächste woche wird erstmal der kanzler
gewählt da werden die minister bestimmt
und dann wird es darüber eine
entscheidung geben und es wird so weit
ich das heute war es sehr schnell zu
einer debatte kommt im deutschen
bundestag wo dann eben wie gesagt jeder
abgeordnete jeder abgeordnete
entscheiden kann wie sie abstimmt es
wird eine debatte geben wie wir es
übrigens auch zu anderen themen haben
thema paragraf 218 thema 219 oder auch
frage sterbehilfe auch das sind
gewissensentscheidungen die wir immer
sehr seriös diskutiert habe und ich
freue mich dass wir das thema im pflicht
genauso seriös jetzt im bundestag
diskutieren angesichts der dramen die
sich vor allen dingen in bayern
thüringen und sachsen abspielen und
insofern ist das eine der demokratie
sehr würdige debatte ja eine noch
weitere debatte ist ja jetzt im moment
auch das thema wie lange man eigentlich
als vollständig gegen korona geimpft
gilt denn es heißt ja nach sechs monaten
ist eben der vollständigen impfschutz
nicht mehr da wie sehen sie das oder
schweizer gestern gesagt nach sechs
monaten müsste man sich noch impfen
freundin genau wir haben mal kurz rein
dauert nur eine sekunde
wir wissen auf alle fälle dass die
jetzige dass der vollständige impfschutz
mit zwei impfungen anders als gehofft im
frühjahr zum beispiel
nicht die wirkung hat dass er für so
lange zeit reicht und deshalb ist es
jetzt ja so wichtig dass viele
bürgerinnen bürger sich anstellen was
sie machen und sich ärgern darüber dass
es nicht gut genug klappt zimmermann wie
es da ihre haltung zu
naja vor einem jahr ging man davon aus
der impfstoff hält länger jetzt sind wir
alle klüger auch die wissenschaft kann
man übrigens auch keinen vorwerfen weil
wir ja vor einem jahr gar nicht wussten
oder anderthalb jahren in welcher
dimension dieses virus auf uns zukommt
jetzt gilt es erstmal dass die leute die
dritt impfung bekommen ich schon die
ersten beiden hatten die die ich kenne
die auch hier in meiner heimatstadt
düsseldorf stehen die leute anders das
heißt das muss ausgebaut werden jeder
nach fünf bis sechs monaten ich bin
keine biologin sofort geimpft wird da
ist der wille ja auch da das ist eine
logistische fragen übrigens of the
general breuer das zu organisieren und
das zweite ist dass wir nach wie vor
millionen von menschen haben die noch
nicht mal die erste oder zweite impfung
haben das heißt neben denen die jetzt
gepustet werden also die dritte impfung
bekommen auch die anderen zu motivieren
bitte so vernünftig zu sein im interesse
auch der allgemeinheit das jetzt
anzugehen der zukünftige kanzler sprach
er von 30 millionen impfungen in den
nächsten wochen das ist eine
unglaubliche aufgabe aber ich traue das
den deutschen zu was eben ganz bitter
ist ohne jetzt immer noch die
vergangenheit zu bemühen wir hätten ja
viel früher anfangen können zu impfen
wenn der impfstoff da gewesen wäre in
deutschland das hat der
gesundheitsminister nicht hinbekommen
jetzt ist der impfstoff da jetzt
brauchen wir logistik um alle die zu
erreichen die wollen und dafür ist eben
jetzt general breuer das zu organisieren
und ich will nicht allzu optimistisch
sein aber wir sollten uns jetzt
gemeinsam und das ist auch mein wunsch
an die die heute bei ihnen zu hören und
zu sehen so schnell wie möglich sich
impfen zu lassen nur so kommen wir
gemeinsam aus der krise raus auch wenn
diese impfung jetzt erst in zwei monaten
wirkt ist es allein um eine weitere
welle vorzubeugen einfach lebenswichtig
und ich hoffe dass viele vernünftig sind
und diesen weg gehen aber was bis dahin
frau zimmermann wir hatten heute morgen
den stellvertretenden
fraktionsvorsitzenden frei von der union
hier im gespräch der hat dezidiert einen
lock down sozusagen auch für geimpfte
gefordert auch kontakt beschränkungen
für geimpfte gefordert in deutschland
die schließung von bars auch von kneipen
und diskotheken
großveranstaltungen zudem ist das etwas
das auf uns zukommen wird mit der ampel
also ich kann ihnen gar nicht sagen was
auf uns zukommen wird es wird schlicht
sie mit dem verhalten
zu tun haben die vernünftig die leute
sind und zwar immer daran gelegen so
wenig wie möglich zu schließen das ist
keine überraschung das geht auch hier
können sie es außer einigen frau
strack-zimmermann können sie es
ausschließen dass es auch eine art von
lockdown für geimpfte geben wird also
ich möchte heute ausschließen dass es so
etwas gibt ich hoffe dass ich vor allen
dingen das ist lassen sie mich lassen
sie mich das bitte nicht so kurz nicht
so reduziert sagen es geht doch jetzt
vor allen dingen darauf in den regionen
also zu ich nehme jetzt mal bayern weil
er so weder ja auch immer da auffällt
dass er ratschläge gibt und es in seinem
eigenen land nicht wirklich auf die
kette bekommt da wo die instanzen hoch
sind da wo die impfquote gering ist wird
es wahrscheinlich so lokalen lockdown
scom aber was soll ich den leuten in
schleswig-holstein sagen da ist die
inzidenz bei wenn ich richtig heute sehe
bei 150 in bayern über 1500 also sie
sehen die unterschiede und deswegen muss
jedes land ist dafür verantwortlich
jedes bundesland jetzt für sich schauen
wie sind die instanzen und was macht
sinn aber ich glaube dass mit dem g2 in
restaurants dass dort geprüft wird wer
kommt also nur geimpfte und genesene
dass wir damit in die richtige richtung
gehen bevor wir die läden schließen
sollten wir dafür sorgen dass ungeimpfte
in diese etablissements restaurants
einfach nicht mehr reinkommen das halte
ich für den richtigen weg dass man jetzt
die geimpften die sich wirklich tadellos
verhalten haben mit im kollektiv haft
ist schwierig aber wenn diese instanzen
natürlich durch die decke gehen da
lassen sie uns noch mal sprechen ich bin
keine virologin ich bin keine ärztin da
bitte ich auch um verständnis aber ziel
muss es sein und das ist mir wirklich
wichtig und uns wichtig es darf nicht
mehr zu schulschließungen kommen denn
wissen sie wir reden viel über
gesundheit und das ist elementar
aber wir haben auch eine soziale
fürsorge für kinder für jugendliche für
menschen gehen der ausbildung sind dass
kinder wieder zu hause beschult werden
auszubildende dich in die ausbildung
können studentinnen und studenten im
vierten semester immer noch nicht die
uni von innen gesehen haben führt zu
irrsinnig sozialen verwerfungen
und das müssen wir auch in den blick
nehmen neben dem gesundheitlichen themen
ein ganz wichtiger mann und frau stark
zimmermann dass man eben da die kinder
nicht vergisst vielen dank für dieses
interview ich danke ihnen